All right, so we're going to be continuing with chapter 7. This is the third and final part part C.
Again, if you like this video, please give it a thumbs up. If you have any questions, please feel free to email me.
Leave a message in the comments below. Also, please be sure to subscribe when you subscribe.
As soon as the new videos are posted up, you guys will be the first ones to know about them.
And please share with your friends. So moving forward, we will now go into the appendicular skeleton.
So we've completed the axial skeleton. Now we're going to talk about all the bones that are off to the side that are lateral to the axial skeleton.
So the two main girdles that your appendicular skeleton consists of are the pectoral girdle and the pelvic girdle.
Now everything, the pectoral girdle, it attaches all your upper body limbs to the trunk.
And the pelvic girdle, it attaches all your lower body limbs to the trunk.
So we're going to first be talking about the pectoral girdle. This is also known as your shoulder girdle.
So the pectoral girdle, again, another name for it is the shoulder girdle.
The bones that are made up of are your clavicles, which are coming in as the collar bones anteriorly,
and then your shoulder blade, or more specifically, the correct anatomical term for that is the scapula posteriorly.
So both clavicles and scapulae, these are the two bones that form the pectoral girdle.
Now, in addition to these bones, the muscles that are associated, that are attached to these bones,
the combination of these things, these are what forms your shoulders.
Now, anteriorly, the medial end of the clavicles, they are articulated with the sternum.
And the distal end of the clavicle, they meet the scapula laterally.
Now, the scapula, it's not attached to the axial skeleton.
It actually, it's held in place by muscles that are attached to it, that form the shoulder joint.
And this is one of the reasons why it has such a huge range of motion.
So only the clavicle attaches to the axial skeleton.
The scapula, this allows the scapula to move more freely across the thorax.
And again, this is how you end up getting a lot of motion in your arm.
Now, the socket, the other part of it is the socket of the shoulder joint, it's called the glenoid cavity.
Now, it's a shallow and it's very poorly reinforced.
So one of the downsides of that is that you can dislocate your upper arm quite easily from it.
However, the other part of it is because of this glenoid cavity.
Now, it's circular in nature.
And when you look at your upper arm, excuse me, when you look at your upper arm,
it has a socket that's also circular.
And because of this, this is how you end up getting a very wide range of motion and also a lot of flexibility.
Be sure you view this video, this animation at the N.P., the website, if you have online access,
or when you purchase the book, there's a DVD in your book, be sure you look at this.
This will be very helpful for you to understanding the movements that you have at the petrol griddle.
Now, so here you go, this is the clavicle, this is your collarbone.
So notice, immediately, it's attached or anchored to the manubrum of your sternum.
And again, laterally, it articulates with the scapula.
Now, this is this glenoid cavity of the scapula.
And this glenoid cavity is what articulates with the head of this humerus.
This is your upper arm bone.
And again, it's because of this cavity, and also because of the fact that this shoulder griddle,
it's not anchored posteriorly to your vertebral column that you end up having all the flexibility
and this incredible range of motion of your upper arm.
And this is a chromium end of the scapula.
So this is where these two, the scapula and the clavicle meet is this acromial clavicular joint.
The acromial clavicular joint.
Now, the clavicles, it's commonly referred to as the collarbones.
This is an S-shaped bone.
Now, the sternal end, it articulates, as you saw in the previous picture, with the sternum,
with the manubrum of the sternum, medially.
And then it's the flattened acromial end of this clavicle.
It articulates laterally with the scapula.
The medial tutors of the clavicle, it's convex anteriorly.
It's lateral third is concave anteriorly.
Now, its superior surface is quite smooth, but when you look at the inferior surface,
it's rigid and grooved because of the ligaments and by the muscles that attach to it.
So the trapezoid line and the conid tubercle, these are anchoring points for a ligament
which runs to attach to the scapula.
So aside from anchoring many muscles, the clavicle also acts as a brace.
So they hold the scapula and arms out laterally away from the narrow superior part of the thorax.
Now, this bracing function becomes obvious when the clavicle is fractured.
Your entire shoulder region, it collapses medially.
The clavicle also transforms compression forces from your upper limbs to the axial skeleton.
Now, the clavicle, it's not a very strong bone and it's likely to become fractured,
especially when you're falling down and you stretch your arm out to break the fall.
There's a high probability, again, depending on other factors,
you know, a person's weight, how high you're falling from, how much force you're falling down with,
and, again, the position of your arm and the body when you hit the ground.
But, yeah, that clavicle can fracture.
Now, with that said, it is a fragile bone.
But in individuals that work out a lot, people that are lifting weights
or people that are doing a lot of manual labor, you notice that this bone actually becomes larger.
And, again, it's part of the bone, remember, it starts to thicken, remember what we learned about bones.
So, it starts to thicken, but then also the muscles, they're also growing.
So, you know, the combination of both the larger muscles and the bone being thicker,
that makes it a little bit more stronger.
So, here's the bone, this is your clavicle right over here.
So, this is a sternal end, this is the part that's going to be articulating immediately with the sternum.
And this is the acromial end, that's going to be articulating with the scapula laterally.
So, again, notice the shape of it, all right, how it is, and notice that this part starts to flatten out,
while this part stays more rounded.
Now, as you go to the other side, when you look at this inferior review,
you can see these, the trapezoid lines very clearly.
Also, you can see this conoid tube look that we talked about.
And these are where ligaments are going to be attaching to hold the scapula, to attach the scapula.
Now, the next bone that we're going to be looking at is the scapula.
So, the scapula, it's also called the shoulder blade.
It's a thin triangular flat bone that we find on the dorsal surface of your rib cage
between the second and seventh costals.
Now, each scapula, it has three borders.
The superior border is the shortest and sharpest border.
The medial, or it's also known as the vertebral border, it parallels the vertebral column.
Now, the thick lateral or axillary border, this is the part that you find right at your armpits,
and it ends superiorly in a small shallow fossa that we call the glenoid cavity.
And it's within this glenoid cavity that the head of the humerus, which is your upper arm bone,
will be articulating at the scapula's three corners or angles.
The superior scapula border meets the medial border at the superior angle
and the lateral border at the lateral angle.
Now, the medial and lateral borders, they join at the inferior angle.
And the inferior angle, it moves extensively as the arm is raised and lowered.
Now, let's look at some of the features of the bone that we find on the scapula.
Now, the anterior or the coastal surface of the scapula, it's concave and it's relatively featureless.
It's the posterior surface of the scapula that we find in the landmarks.
Now, the very first thing that you're going to see is a prominent spine.
Now, you can also feel this very easily.
If you reach back and you go just touching your shoulder area
and you feel that big bump that's present, that's the spine of your scapula.
Now, the spine, it ends laterally in an enlarged, rough and triangular projection that's called the acromion.
Now, the acromion, it articulates with the acromial end of the clavicle.
And this is what forms this acromial clavicular joint that we looked at a few slides ago.
Now, projecting anteriorly from the superior scapular border, we have the corticoid process.
Now, the corticoid process, it helps anchor the bicep muscles of your arm.
And when you flex your arm, again, the muscle that shortens and pops up, that's your bicep muscle.
Now, it's bounded by the super scapular notch and by the glenoid cavity laterally.
Now, the super scapular notch, it serves as a nerve passage.
We also see several large fossa or fossae that appear on both the anterior and posterior aspects of the scapula.
And they're named according to their location.
So, the infraspinus and the supraspinus fossa, these are inferior and superior located to the spine.
Now, the subscapular fossa, this is a shallow concavity that's formed by the entire anterior scapular surface.
Now, lying within these fossae, we find muscles that have the bare names of these fossae.
So, here's the scapula, and this is the right scapula.
And you're looking at the anterior, this is an anterior view.
So, this entire region, this is a subscapular fossa.
Now, because this is the right scapula, this is going to be the medial border.
This is the inferior angle, and then this is a superior angle.
So, you have a superior and inferior angle.
Now, this is the lateral border.
Remember, lateral border, this is the right scapula, and you can find out, again, so if you put yourself,
if you take this and you flip it around backwards, if you flip it around at 180 degrees,
and then you're going to end up putting it to yourself.
So, you'll see that this is going to be where your right arm is.
So, this part, this is where the head of your humerus is going to be attaching to you over here.
Now, this is your acromionin, this is the coracoid process.
This is a glenoid cavity.
This is the suprascapular notch.
This is a superior border.
Now, let's look at, there you go.
This is the posterior view of this right scapula.
So, there you go.
So, as you're looking at it, this is how it's going to be positioned in your body.
So, when you take your left arm and you, you know, you feel the back of your shoulder,
and this is that shoulder blade that you call.
This is that spine.
Okay?
Now, this is a supraspinous fossa, and this is the infraspinous fossa.
So, this is the spine.
So, above the spine, super below infra.
This is the medial border.
This is the lateral border.
And again, this is that acromion end, and this is the coracoid process.
And you can also see the suprascapular notch over here.
So, once again, this is a lateral view of this scapula.
So, notice over here you had this infraglinoid tubercle.
So, this is going to be an attation point for a muscle.
This is an inferior angle.
The subscapular fossa over here.
The infra spinous fossa is over there.
You can see the glenoid cavity.
So, this is where you're the head of your upper arm bone, the head of the humerus.
This is where it's going to be articulating at over here.
You have the coracoid process right there, and the chromion end over there.
Let's see.
All right.
Now we're going to be going and looking at the bones that make up your upper limb.
So, there's 30 bones that form the framework of each of your upper limbs.
So, in general, the three main bones are the arms, the forearm arms, and then your hand bones.
And this is where you find the most number of bones in our hand.
Now, the upper arm is made up of the humerus.
This is a long bone, and it articulates with your scapula.
Then you have your forearm.
Now, your forearm, it consists of two bones, your radius and ulna.
Now, when you stick your hands outwards, again, in the anatomical position, the bone that's on the side of your thumb.
The bone that runs on the same side as your thumb does, that's your radius.
Okay?
And then the bone that runs along the same side as your pinky does, this is your ulna.
So, you have your radius and ulna.
So, remember, a little finger, a little finger, you have ulna, and your thumb, you have the radius.
Then you have the bones that make up your hand.
Your hand is made up of eight bones that make up your wrist, which are called the carples.
Then you have five bones that make up the bones that make up your palms, which are the metacarpals.
And then you have 14 bones that make up your fingers, which are called the phalanges.
Now, the humerus is the only bone that makes up your upper arm.
It's the largest and longest bone of your upper limb.
It articulates superiorly with the glenoid cavity of the scapula, and inferiorly, it articulates with the radius and the ulna.
Now, these are the two lower arm bones.
Now, remember, the radius is on the thumb side, and the ulna is on your pinky, your little finger side.
These are very common test questions that make sure you don't forget this, stressing this a few times, so you guys take note of that.
Now, let's look at some of the features of your humerus.
Now, at the proximal end of the humerus, you find this smooth spherical head.
Now, this is a part that fits into the glenoid cavity of the scapula.
Now, because of the shape of this head and the structure of the glenoid cavity,
this is what allows this entire bone to hang freely at the sides of your body.
Now, immediately inferior to the head, we have this constriction, and this is called the anatomical neck.
Now, inferior to this, we have the lateral aspect.
We have this greater tubercle, and on the medial aspect, we have this lesser tubercle.
Now, between the greater and the lesser tubercle, we find this intertubicular sulcus.
Another preferred is this bicepital groove.
Now, these tubercles, these are sites for attachments of your rotator cuff muscles.
The intertubicular sulcus, it guides the tendon of the bicep muscles of your arms to attach it to the point
at the rim of the glenoid cavity, which is called the supraglenoid tubercle.
Now, notice that these names, they describe the location, the named after the location.
So, supraglenoid, okay, above the glenoid, the tubercle they find above the glenoid cavity,
supraglenoid tubercle.
Now, just distal to the tubercle, we have the surgical neck.
Now, it's named the surgical neck because this is a site where most frequently we find the fractures of this bone take place.
Now, as we continue to move along this bone, now midway down the shaft, on the lateral aspect, we have this V-shaped deltoid tuberosity.
This is a roughened attachment site for another muscle of your shoulder.
This is, again, now this tuberosity is named after the muscle that it's attached to.
So, the deltoid tuberosity, so which muscle attaches to it, the deltoid muscle.
Now, close to that, we have this radial groove that runs obliquely down the posterior aspect of the shaft.
Now, this marks the core set, your radial nerve is going to be running through.
This is an important nerve of your upper limb.
Now, at the dislike of the humerus, we have two condyles.
Immediately, we find the trochlea, and laterally, we find the capitulum.
The capitulum, it looks like a ball-like shape it has, and the trochlea, it kind of looks like an hour less that sits on its side.
Now, the condyles, the articulate with the ulna and the radius, both these condyles are also flanked by the medial and lateral epicon dials.
Now, these are muscle attachment sites.
Now, above these condyles, we find the medial and lateral supracondylarages.
So, medial and lateral supracondylarages.
Now, one of the nerves that passes through these ridges is the medial ridge is the ulnar nerve.
So, when you hit your elbow and you're like, "Oh, I hit my funny bone."
Well, that's not really your funny bone.
That's your ulnar nerve that you just hit that causes this pain.
Now, superior to the trochlea on the anterior surface, we have this coronite fossa.
Now, on the posterior surface, we have the deeper alecranon fossa.
Now, these two depressions, they allow the corresponding process of the ulna to move freely when you bend or flex our forearm.
Now, the smaller radial fossa, which is lateral to the coronite fossa, it receives the head of the radius.
Again, when we flex our forearm at the elbow.
So, here we go.
Let's look at the photographs.
Now, this is an actual photo of the humerus.
So, this is the head of the humerus over here.
This is the lesser tubercle, and this is the greater tubercle over there.
And then, here we have the inter tubercular sulcus right over there, in this area there.
This is the deltoid tuberosity.
Again, this is where the muscle attaches to, your deltoid muscle.
And then, as you move down, you can see the radial fossa over here.
And here's the coronite fossa over here.
This is the capitulum over here, right over here.
And what else can we see over here?
And then, of course, you have the trochlea in this end.
So, it's the trochlea.
So, notice this is kind of like an hourglass inside.
So, you have your capitulum and trochlea.
Now, let's look at the drawings.
So, again, it's a little bit easier to see over here, in the illustrations.
So, again, you can see the deltoid tuberosity here.
And this is also an anterior view.
And then, right over here, you can see the intertuberculosurcus very, very clearly.
This is a lesser tubercle and the greater tubercle.
What else do we see?
So, this is an anatomical neck right over here.
This is a neck right over here.
The anatomical neck, this part, over there.
And then, as you move in this picture, there you go.
You can see it right over there, the anatomical neck, right over there.
As you move down, let's see.
So, this is the lateral super chondola ridge right over there.
Here, you can see the coronite fossa and the radial fossa.
So, this is a trochlea over here.
And then, the capitulum.
So, notice this kind of looks like it's hourglass.
It's on its side, trochlea, capitulum.
And now, let's look at the posterior view.
So, this is the area that's of interest.
So, this is a trochlea.
This is what it looks like posteriorly.
And notice that it creates this groove here.
This is the olecranine fossa.
All right.
And then, here's your lateral epicondyle.
And this is your medial epicondyle.
Okay.
So, medial epicondyle, lateral epicondyle.
Again, your deltoid tuberosity.
This is a surgical neck.
Okay.
Surgical neck.
And this is the anatomical neck.
Anatomical neck.
Surgical neck.
Two different things.
Again, over here, here, this is a closeup of the elbow area, elbow region.
So, this is the capitulum.
And this is an anterior view.
Capitulum and trochlea right over there.
You can see the corner fossa now very clearly.
And let's see.
We have the coronary fossa.
Here's a medial epicondyle.
This part, you have the lateral epicondyle.
It's going to be over here.
As you move down, so you can see over here, this is the head of the radius.
And this is the ulna.
Okay.
So, this is the radial -- between these two -- well, we'll just not go down to these bones.
But what you want to look at exists, this is the cornet process of the ulna.
All right.
Cornet process of the ulna.
That's articulating with the trochlea.
So, when you look at it backwards -- now, this bone right over here, this ulna.
This is that bone right here.
Now, the olecranon process of the ulna, this part is what's going to be articulating with
the olecranon fossa.
So, let's go back over here.
And this right over here, it's olecranon fossa.
This bone over here, this olecranon of these ulna and the olecranon fossa.
So, this is -- this is what locks your elbow in place.
Okay.
This is what prevents this hyperex tension from occurring.
So, here you can see the lateral epic kind of very clearly here.
Again, you can see the head of the radius.
This is the neck of the -- well, let's not go down over there.
We'll move forward when you get to that part.
So, now, we're going to be looking at the bones that make up your forearm.
Again, these are the two, the radius and the ulna.
So, the proximal ends of the radius and ulna.
Again, they're going to be articulating with the humerus, as we saw in the previous slide.
Now, distally, they're going to be articulating, articulating at the radial ulna joint.
There's also a membrane that we find between these two bones called the intra-aseous membranes,
and it connects the radius and ulna entire the entire lanticate.
It helps stabilize them.
Keep them in place.
Now, remember, what we said about the radius and the ulna.
The ulna, this is on the side of your -- again, when you have your arm extended in the anatomical position,
and you have your arm placed in the anatomical position.
The ulna, it's on the small finger side, okay?
So, it's on the medial aspect of your forearm.
Now, this is the longer of the two bones.
It's slightly a little bit longer than the radius is.
And it has the main responsibility for forming the elbow joint with your humerus.
Now, it's proximal, and it looks like the adjustable end of a monkey wrench.
It bears these two prominent processes that are called the olekronon and the coronoid process.
So, remember this, olekronon and coronite process.
Now, these two processes, they're separated by a deep concavity, which is the trochlear notch.
Now, together, both these processes, they grip the trochlear of the humerus.
And this forms this hinge joint, okay, that allows the forearm to extend, but not hyper extend, all right?
And also, again, it also -- the movement for both flexion and extension.
Now, remember, this olekronon process, it goes and it fits -- it articulates with that olekronon fossa of the humerus.
And this is what's preventing this hyper extension from occurring, okay?
The posterior olekronon process, it forms the angle of the elbow when the forearm is flexed.
So, flex your arms up, and you see that little sharp little part?
That's -- this is what that is, all right?
This is the post -- this is the posterior olekronon process.
Now, on the lateral sides of the coronoid process, we have a small depression.
That's called the radial notch.
Now, this is where the ulna articulates with the head of the radius.
Now, distally, the ulnar shaft, it narrows and ends in an odd-like head.
Medial to the head, we have a silent process from where we have a ligament that runs to the wrist.
Now, the other one of the forearms, the radius, this is found on the lateral aspect of your arm forearm
when you're in the anatomical position.
So, this bone is thin at its proximal end.
And as you move down the length of that bone, distally, it widens.
So, it's the opposite of what we find in the ulna.
Now, the head of the radius is shaped similar to that of the head of a nail.
The superior surface of this head is concave and it articulates with the capitulum of the humerus.
Now, immediately, the head of the articulates with the radial notch of the ulna.
Now, inferior to the head, we have this rough radial tuberosity.
Now, this anchors your bicep muscles of your forearm.
So, this is the other part that this bicep muscles anchor to.
Distally, where the radius is expands, it has a medial ulnar notch.
Now, this articulates with the ulna and it has a lateral-styled process.
Now, this is an anchoring site for ligaments that run to the wrist.
Now, between these two sites, the radius, it's concave where it articulates with the carpal bones of your wrist.
Now, let's look at the pictures.
So, here you go.
Now, again, remember, in the anatomical position, when you're looking at this bone, notice that this is the ulna.
This is the bone that's on the medial aspect of your body.
So, this is closer to where your pinky is.
This is the longer of these two bones.
The radius is on the thumb side.
This is the shorter of the two.
So, let's look over here.
This is the styloid process of the radius.
This is the styloid process of the ulna.
Now, this is a radial tuberosity over here.
And this is the neck of the radius.
This is the head.
This is the coronite process, the olecranine process of the ulna.
And now, let's look at the illustrations over here, the anterior view.
Again, this is the olecranine process over here.
You can see the trochlear notch over there, the coronite process right over there.
This is the head of the radius, the neck, and then this is the radial notch right over here.
And here's an inter-RCS membrane.
It's flexible, connected tissue over here.
And then, let's look at the posterior view.
So, posterior view, again, this is the ulna and this is the radius.
So, this is the neck of the radius.
Again, you can see the head of the radius.
This is the olecranine process over there.
And this is the part that's going to be locking in into the lecranine fossa of the humerus.
Again, you can see the silid process over here of the radius and silid process of the ulna.
And then, here is this, the ulnar notch.
So, here's a close-up again.
So, this is the olecranine process here, the coronite process there, the trochlear notch here, the radial notch here.
And now, let's look over here.
So, once again, this is the, what do we have?
So, yeah, this is an articulation point for one of your, your wrist bones, called the scafoid.
This is for another, another point where this, another wrist bone called the lunate is going to be articulating over here.
This, and remember, this is that radius bone right over here.
And this is the, the stullard process of the ulna over here.
This is the head of the ulna.
So, notice how the head of the ulna, it articulates with this, the, the ulnar notch of the radius over here.
It's a little bit easier to see at this picture.
So, now, let's look at some homocytic imbalances.
So, a coals fracture, this is a break in the distal end of the radius.
Now, it's a very common fracture because when people fall, they attempt to break the fall,
and what do you have?
You have your hands stretched out.
So, you end up getting this, this coals fracture that occurs.
Now, we're going to be looking at the bones that make up your hand.
So, the very first bones that we're going to be looking at are going to be your wrist bones, okay,
which are called the, the, the carpals.
After that, you have the bones that make up your palms, your metacarpals,
and then you have your fingers called the phalanges.
So, collectively, the, the carpals are also known as the carpus.
And these are eight bones that make up your wrist.
And we find them lined up in two rows.
We have a proximal row, and the, and the bones that we find in this proximal row,
going from lateral to medial are scaphoid, lunate, triquitrim, and pisciform.
Okay, scaphoid, lunate, triquitrim, and pisciform.
Now, the distal row, the bones we find here, again, going from lateral to medial are the trapezium,
trapezoid, capitate, and hammate, okay.
So, scaphoid, lunate, triquitrim, pisciform, trapezium, trapezoid, capitate, hammate.
Now, only the scaphoid, lunate, and triquitrim, they form the wrist joint.
Also, there's a handful of pneumonics that you can use.
The, the book gives you some, I think it says, Sally left the party to take Cindy home.
You can use that, or you can go online, Google some, there's a handful of other things,
whatever works for you, go ahead and use it.
Now, we're going to be looking at the metacarpus.
So, now, you have five bones, they're five long bones, whereas also previously the, I think
I forgot to mention, the, the wrist bones, your carples, these are short bones, okay.
So, now we're going back to looking at the long bones.
Now, these, uh, metacarpals, uh, so these five metacarpals, which are long bones,
they form your palm, palms, your palms, on both hands.
The, the base, it articulates with your wrist bones, your carples, and the heads, they
articulate, uh, with the phalanges.
Metacarpals are a number from one to five, uh, so your first number one is going to be a thumb and the number five is going to be a pinky.
Now, metacarpal one, uh, which again, it says, that's associated with the thumb.
This is the shortest, and it's the most mobile, uh, of these, uh, of the metacarpals.
Now, it occupies a more anterior position than some of the other metacarpals.
Now, the joint between the metacarpals one and the trapezium, it's a unique saddle joint that allows the opposition to occur.
Now, this is what allows you to touch all the tips of your other fingers.
Now, as we found in the metacarpals, your fingers, they're also a number from one to five, uh, starting with your thumb.
So, your digit number one, that's your thumb, and digit five is your, your pinky.
Now, the other name for your thumb or digit one is also called the polyx, okay?
So, polyx is digit one, and it's made up of two bones.
It does not have a middle phalanx, okay? It doesn't have a middle part.
The rest of the bones, the rest of your digits, number is two, three, four, and five, uh, your middle, uh,
sorry, your index, middle, ring, and a little finger, they're all made up of three bones.
It consists of a distal, a medial, and a proximal phalanx.
Now, let's look at the picture of your, uh, your, your hand, okay?
So, uh, these are your wrist bones, okay? Your, uh, your carples, your metacarpals, and then the phalanges.
So, um, also, this is your forearm.
So, now, let's look at these bones that make up your wrist.
So, remember, you have two rows of four bones each.
So, here's the first row of four bones, and this is the second row of four bones.
So, this is just scafoid, lunate, triketrum, pissiform.
And then you have trapezium, trapezoid, uh, capitate, and hamate, okay?
Scafoid, lunate, triketrum, pissiform, trapezium, trapezoid, capitate, and hamate.
And again, you can see the same bones over here.
So, scafoid, lunate, triketrum, and again, notice you cannot see, uh, the pissiform over here,
because it's settling on top of, uh, the, the triketrum.
Uh, but over here, you can see the trapezium, trapezoid, capitate, and the hamate, okay?
Now, after that, uh, moving along distally, you have your, uh, the bones that make up your palm, okay?
Your metacarpals.
So, remember, the carples and metacarpals, uh, this is where the carples meet, okay?
These other bones, metacarpals, they met the carples.
Uh, now, uh, one, two, three, four, five, okay?
Uh, five bones over here also.
Now, uh, and then afterwards, you have your phalanges.
So, notice the thumb only has a proximal and a distal part, right?
Proximal distal failings.
Now, the rest of the fingers, they have, uh, three parts.
One, two, three, one, two, three, one, two, three.
So, this is your proximal, middle, and distal phalanx, right?
And these are all collectively called the phalanges, okay?
Your phalanges are your fingers, guys.
So, everybody raise your hand in the ear and wiggle your phalanges.
Okay.
Uh, now, uh, so, yeah, the median, uh, some homie-static imbalances we're going to be talking about now.
So, the median nerve and tendons, they travel through the car, uh, the carpal tunnel.
Uh, this is a tunnel that's formed by ligaments, uh, that run through the wrist.
So, carpal tunnel syndrome can occur, uh, from overuse and inflammation of the tendons.
Uh, and then what ends up happening is, now that you have inflammation in these tendons,
they're going to start pushing down on the median nerve.
And this causes this tingling and numbness.
So, repetitive, uh, stress injury also is called, so, uh, a certain line of work.
If you're constantly doing something, so, if you're sitting in front of a keyboard,
you have poor posture, and, you know, every day, eight hours a day, you're, uh, you know,
you're putting, uh, causing, uh, this extra weight, uh, to come down on these ligaments,
and then they start to get inflamed.
And then this is what causes this carpal tunnel syndrome.
Uh, so, how do you correct it?
Well, you stop doing the action that's causing it in the first place.
Uh, that, you know, hopefully that'll do the trick.
If not, then, you know, you have to take medications, and you have to have surgery.
Or, again, there's alternative methods, you can also try, you can go to, uh, a chiropractor
to see if they can help, or you can also try a TCM, which is traditional Chinese medicine.
So, things like acupressure, acupuncture, they seem to help also.
Now we're going to be moving down, uh, to, uh, the pelvic girdle, okay?
So, now we're going to be looking at your lower limb.
Now, the pelvic girdle or the hip girdle, it attaches a lower limb to the axial skeleton.
Uh, it also transmits the full weight of your upper body to the lower limbs, and it supports
the visceral organs of your pelvis.
Uh, the pelvic girdle is formed by a pair of hip bones, which are also called the oscoxi,
or coxobones.
Uh, each hip bones, it unites, uh, with this partner anteriorly and, uh, with the sacrum posteriorly.
Now, uh, this bone, though it does provide less mobility compared to your shoulder joint,
it's much more stronger and a lot more stable.
There's, uh, three bones that are fused to form, uh, this coxobone.
They are the ilium, ischium, and pubis.
Uh, the ischium is a part that you're sitting on, uh, sitting down up.
The ilium is, that's a part that's, uh, that, that, uh, goes upwards, uh, superiorly,
and the pubis is the anteriormost, uh, part of your coxobone.
There's also a deep socket that's found, uh, at the pelvic bone called the acetabulum,
and this is what, uh, what receives the head of your thigh bone.
We, uh, the, that specific part is called the head of the femur.
The femur is the name for your thigh bone.
And as we saw, uh, in your, uh, your shoulder girdle, the part that received your, the head of your upper arm bone,
your, uh, the, the, the humerus, uh, was the, the glenoid cavity.
So over here, it's not the, it's the acetabulum that receives the head of the femur.
So here you go.
This is your, uh, your, well, your pelvic girdle over here, and all in all.
So notice that immediately the pelvic girdle, it articulates with your sacrum.
Now, uh, so this is your sacrum.
That's your cossics over there. So anteriorly, most memorized said this is called the pubis.
Okay. This part is the pubis.
Now, this is the ischium. This is the part you're sitting on.
And the flared part that's, that goes upward. This is the ileum.
Okay. So ileum, pubis, and ischium.
Um, and this is like the pubic synthesis.
Again, this is, uh, connect to tissue over here.
And, uh, during childbirth, uh, this will stretch a little bit,
and this is what accommodates, uh, the, the child from, uh, being delivered vaginally.
Um, so, uh, let's look at some of the structures that you're going to be seeing here.
So this is acetabulum right over here.
And this acetabulum is what's going to be receiving the head of, uh, the femur, okay?
Which is your, this one right here, this thigh bone.
That's the head of the right over there.
And we're going to be looking at this bone detail as, as we move through.
Uh, so this is the, the pubic tubercle.
This is the, this is the pubic, uh, crust.
And again, this is the synthesis, okay?
The pubic synthesis, the junction.
This is the pelvic brim over here.
Uh, this is the, the anterior inferior iliac spine.
And this is the anterior superior iliac spine.
This is the iliac crust over here.
Okay, this is the sacral iliac joint.
Okay, sacrum, sacral iliac joint, sacral iliac joint.
This is the iliac fossa over here.
Okay.
The, the depression.
And, uh, I think we covered just about everything.
So now let's look at these three bones.
So iliac is even pubis.
Remember, these are the three bones that fuse to form your, uh, coxel bone.
So iliac, as we saw in the previous, uh, picture, this forms the superior region of the coxel bone.
And the auricular surfaces of this iliac bone, uh, are what articulate with the sacrum to form this sacral iliac joint.
The issue, this is the, the posterior inferior part of your hip bone.
And again, this is the part that you're sitting on, sitting down on right now if you're sitting.
And pubis, this is the anterior portion of your hip bone.
So the, the pubis joints, it comes together at that pubic symphysis joint.
Now, uh, again, the superior region of the hip bone, this is your iliac.
Okay.
And, uh, the iliac, it, it's made up of a body and a wing like iliac.
Now the superior margins of the iliac, they're called the, the, the iliac crest.
Okay.
Now, uh, the iliac crest, um, we find lots of muscles attaching over here.
Uh, each iliac crest, it ends anteriorly in the blunt anterior superior iliac spine.
And posteriorly in the sharp posterior superior iliac spine.
Now located below these, uh, we have some less prominent anterior and posterior iliac spine.
Now all these spines, they're attachment points for muscles of the trunk, uh, the hip and thighs.
Now, inferior to the posterior iliac spine, the iliac, it indents deeply to form this, uh,
the greater sciatic notch through which the sciatic nerve passes to enter the thigh.
Now the broad posterior lateral surface of the iliac, which is called the gluteal surface,
is crossed by three ridges.
You have the posterior, anterior, and inferior gluteal lines.
Uh, and this is where the gluteal muscles attach to you.
So in other words, these gluteal muscles, these are the muscles that make up your butt, your butt muscles.
Now the medial surface of the iliac alla, it shows a concivity that's called the iliac fossa.
Now posterior to the iliac fossa, we have this rough and auricular surface that articulates with the sacrum that forms this sacroiliac joint.
Now the weight of the body is transmitted from the spine to the pelvis through the sacroiliac joint.
Now running inferiorly and anteriorly from the auricular surface, we have this ridge that's called the arcuate line.
Now the arcuate line, it helps define this pelvic brim, which is the superior margin of the true pelvis.
Now the issue, it forms a posterior, inferior part of your hip bone.
And it kind of looks like an arc shape that it has.
It has a thicker, superior body that joins the iliac.
It joins the iliac and it has a thinner, inferior amis that joins the pubis anteriorly.
Now the issue of it has three important markings.
It's issue of spine, it projects medially into the pelvic cavity and serves as a point of attachment of the sacrospinal ligament running from the sacrum.
Just inferior to the issue of spine, we have this lesser sciatic notch.
A number of blood vessels and nerves, they pass through this notch to supply the anal genital area.
The inferior surface of the ishial body is rough and grossly thickened as the ishial tuberosity.
Now when we're sitting down on our body, this is the part of the issue that you're sitting on.
Is this ishial tuberosity?
So all of our weight is born entirely by this ishial tuberosity on both ishia.
And these are the strongest parts of the hip bone.
Now there's also a massive ligament that runs from the sacrum to the ishial tuberosity, which is called the sacred tuberous ligament.
And this helps hold the pelvis together.
In addition to that, the ishial tuberosity, it also serves as a site for your hamstring muscles to attach to.
Now the pubis or the pubic bone, it forms the anterior portion of your hip bone.
In anatomical position, it almost lies horizontally, and your urinary bladder, it's sitting on top of it.
Now the pubis, it's a V-shaped bone.
So the V is made by the superior and inferior Ramai that extends from the medial body.
Now the anterior board of the pubis is thickened to form this pubic crest.
Now at the lateral end of the pubic crest, you have this pubic tubercle.
And at the pubic tubercle, we have the inguider ligament that attaches to it.
Now as the two Ramai of the pubic bone run laterally to join with the body of the Ramis of that ishium,
it defines a large opening in the hip that we call the obtrader foramen.
And through this obtrader foramen, we have blood vessels of nerves that pass through it.
Now the bodies of the two pubic bones are joined by fibrocartilage disc, forming this midline pubic symphysis joint.
Now inferior to this pubic symphysis joint, the inferior and pubic Ramai, the inguiderally
forming an inverted V-shaped arch called the pubic arch.
Or sometimes it's also called the sub pubic angle.
So let's look at these illustrations now.
So this is the lateral view of the right hip bone.
So this is the acetabulum right here.
So notice that all three bones form the acetabulum.
You have part of your pubis, your ishium, and the ilium that form this acetabulum.
So now this is the ayla, and this is the iliac crest.
Okay, so remember this entire bone is the ilium.
And this is the anterior superior iliac spine.
And then we have the, let's see what we have when we go down.
So this is the inferior, the anterior iliac spine.
And then you can see the inferior gluteal line over here.
And you can see the anterior gluteal line up over here.
In addition to that, we have this posterior gluteal line that runs down this way.
This is the posterior inferior iliac spine here.
And this is at a greater sciatic notch right over here.
Okay, the greater sciatic notch.
This is the issue of body.
And this is a lesser sciatic notch.
So you have the greater sciatic notch and the lesser sciatic notch.
And this is the issue of tuberosity over here.
This is that obturator foramen.
And then what else can we see here?
So yeah, this is the body of the pubic bone here.
And so this is the inferior pubic remis.
This is the superior pubic remis over here.
And we, yes, let's look over here.
This is the medial view.
Now over here, you can see the, the articular surface of the pubic,
of the pubic bone quite clearly over here.
Now, if you want to work to examine this structure,
you can tell a lot like, for example, if it's a female,
you can tell how many children this female may have had,
just by looking at, by observing this, the articular surface of this pubic bone.
Also, when you look at the angle of both these bones, you can tell, you know,
if, if, if, you know, this, the pelvic bone belongs to a male or a female.
There, there's a handful of other things that you look at aside from that.
But yes, the angle of the pubis also helps to differentiate the sex of the skeleton.
What else can we see here? So, okay.
So here's the articular surface over here.
You can see very clearly.
It's that iliac fossa.
Again, you can see the iliac crest over here.
And again, the obturator foreman, the less acetic notch, the greater acetic notch.
So I think we just spot everything we saw in the previous picture we saw over here.
So now let's talk a little bit more about the pelvic structure and childbearing.
So notice that I said in the previous picture that, you know,
by looking at the pubis, you know, you're able to differentiate
if it's a male or a female, and in addition to that also how many children,
if it is a female, how many children this individual may have had.
Now the pelvis is formed by your hip bone, sacrum, and caustics.
Having said that, there are still differences between a male and a female pelvis.
The female pelvis, it's modified for childbearing.
So it tends to be wider, shallower, lighter, and rounder than that of the male.
Now the female pelvis not only doesn't need to accommodate the fetus to grow,
but it also needs to be able to be large enough to allow for the delivery of the child during child birth.
Now the pelvis is set to consist of a false pelvis and a true pelvis,
that's separated by a pelvic brim.
The pelvic brim is a continuous oval ridge that runs from the pubic crest
through the arcuate lines and sacral promontory.
Now the false pelvis, this is the portion that's superior to the pelvic brim.
It's bonded by the ayla of the ilea laterally and the lumbar vertebrae posteriorly.
Now the false pelvis is really part of the abdomen and it helps support the abdominal viscera
and it doesn't restrict child birth in any way.
Now the true pelvis, this is the region inferior to the pelvic brim that's almost entirely surrounded by bone.
It forms a deep bowl containing the pelvic organs.
Its dimensions, particularly those of its inlets and alkylids,
they're very important for delivery of a baby.
So when a woman is going to the obstetrician for the checkups every so often,
and especially during the ultrasounds, these are going to be measured
to make sure that it's large enough to accommodate the child during labor,
during the delivery process.
If the doctor suspects that it's not adequate enough for delivery,
then at that point they'll probably decide to deliver the baby by caesarean section.
Now the pelvic inlet is the pelvic brim and its widest dimension is from right to left
along the frontal plane and the pelvic outlet, this is the inferior margin of the true pelvis.
Now it's bounded anterior to the pubic arch and laterally by the isha
and posteriorly by the sacrum and caustic.
Now both caustics and ishaal spines, they protrude into the outlet's opening.
So a sharply angled caesarean or an unusually large spines,
they're going to interfere with delivery.
Now the largest dimension of the outlet is the anterior posterior diameter.
So generally what happens during childbirth is that the baby's head, it passes through the inlet.
It rotates so the forehead faces posteriorly and the occiparate anteriorly
and this is a usual position of the baby's head as it leaves
the mother's body.
So during birth, the infant's head, it makes a quarter turn to follow the widest dimension
of the true pelvis.
So this chart over here, it goes over and distinguishes some of the characteristics
between a female and a male pelvic bones.
So again, let's go through this and discuss this a little bit.
So as far as bone thickness goes, in females,
it's going to be lighter, less thick and it's going to be much more smoother.
Now in men's, again, it's going to be heavier, it's going to be thicker
and you're going to have a lot more prominent marking.
Why is that the case?
Well, men have bigger and larger muscles than female do, generally speaking.
So this is why.
Now, in addition to that, as far as the acetabular go, they're farther apart.
Okay, why? Because again, you have much, the wings over here, they're far more,
they're flared out, it's much more wider.
So if you look over here, look at this pelvic brain.
Look how much wider this is.
And when you look at the shape over here, it's almost like an oval shape in the female.
Now when you look at the male, this is more of a heart shaped.
So if you were, you know, if you were to get a hip and you look at it and you kind of see
like this heart shaped form over here, that's a pretty good indication that it's probably a male.
But that should not be the only criteria.
Again, in the female when you look at it, it's going to look a little more like an oval shaped.
So again, the acetabular farther apart in the males, they're going to be closer.
Also, we look at this pubic arch.
In the female, you have this very broad angle that forms over here.
So it's more than 90 degrees, anywhere from between 80 to 90 degrees and beyond.
So look how wide this is.
And when you look at the male pelvis here, the pubic or the sub pubic angle, it's very narrow.
Okay, right over here, look how narrow this is.
So it's, you're going to see a cute angle over here.
So anywhere between 45, 50 to 60 degrees, usually, this is what you'll find.
So in males also, it's tilted less forward.
We're in females, it's tilted forward.
And again, remember, this bone is adapted for childbearing.
And this type of pelvis bone, it's not adapted for childbearing, but it's made to, you know, to accommodate more weight.
As a, you know, think of it this way, men, they have a lot more muscle, they have a heavier build.
So they need to have a lot more muscles and they need to have a much more, again, a stapler, narrower form.
So this is why they're going to get this.
It's how the body is designed between male and females that these structures are different also.
Remember, structure and function over and over again, we've been seeing this and now, you know, you can see that at this level as well.
This is a photograph also, and you can see the two over here.
So look at the female and look at the male.
So it's a little bit harder to distinguish over here, but notice that, you know, the classic is much farther away in females than it is in males.
And the sacrum also, so if you look at the sacrum, it's a wider than it is in the males.
What else can we see?
Yeah, you look at the greater sciatic notch over here, a lot very wide over here.
Whereas in the males is not, it's quite narrow, but it tends to be a little bit, I'm sorry, it tends to be a little bit deeper.
So here it is, this is your greater sciatic notch, much deeper and narrow.
Whereas over here, you have a much wider and a shallow greater sciatic notch.
Again, this is another photograph.
It's poster inferior view.
So when you look at the inlet brim, so notice again, what do we have over here?
In the male, what do you see?
It's almost like this.
You can see it very clearly here.
You have this heart shape structure that forms.
And the female is more of an oval shape that's present.
So again, the inlet, it follows oval from side to side and in the men, it's more heart shaped and much more narrow.
So narrow, wider.
And also, when you look at the outlet, again, this part, the issue tuberosity tends to be much shorter and farther apart than ever.
Whereas in the males, the issue tuberosity is a much longer, sharper and more, they quite more medially as well.
Now we're going to be looking at the lower limb.
Now the lower limb, it carries the entire weight of your body when you're standing up.
Now it's subjected to exceptional forces when you're walking, when you're jumping, when you're running.
There's three parts of the lower limb.
Your thigh, leg and foot.
Now the femur.
This is the first part.
This is the largest and it's the strongest bone in the body.
And it makes up for about one quarter of a person's height.
Now it articulates proximally at the acetabulum of your hip.
And distally, it articulates with the tibia and the patella.
The patella, this is more common known as your knee bone, your kneecap.
It's a seismite bone that we find in the quadriceps tendon and it helps protect this knee joint.
Now we're going to be looking at some of the features of your femur, your thigh bone.
Now the bone like head of the femur, it has a small central pit that's called the fovea capidus.
Now the short ligament of the head of the femur runs from this pit to the acetabulum where it helps secure the femur in place.
The head is carried on a neck that angles laterally to the shaft.
This arrangement reflects the fact that the femur articulates with the lateral aspect of the pelvis.
The neck is the weakest part of the femur and is most often where fractures occur.
Now at the junction of the shaft and neck, we have the lateral greater trochanter and the posterior medial lesser trochanter.
Now these projections serve as sites for your thigh and butt muscles to attach to you.
Now the two trochanters, they're connected by the inter trochanic line anteriorly
and by the prominent inter trochanic crest posteriorly.
Now inferior to the inter trochanic crest on the posterior shaft, we have the gluteal tuberosity.
Now the gluteal tuberosity, it blends into a long vertical ridge called the linear aspra inferiorly.
Now distally, the linear aspra, it diverges.
It forms the medial and lateral supercondular lines.
Now all these markings, these are sites for muscles to attach to you.
Now distally, the femur broadens and ends in the lateral medial condiles.
Now these condiles, you're articulated with the tibia of the leg.
Now the medial lateral epicondiles, they flank the condiles superiorly.
So on the superior part of the medial epicondile is a bump.
Now this is called the adductor tubercle.
The smooth patellar surface between the condiles and the anterior femoral surface, they articulate with the patella.
And again, this is your kneecap.
Now between the condiles on the posterior aspect of the femur, we have this deep u-shaped intercondular fossa.
And superior to that on the shaft, we have this smooth popliteal surface.
So here we go.
Now this is the patella over here, and more commonly your kneecap.
Again, so this is an anterior view, this is the posterior view.
So you can see over here, the lateral condyle, the femur, and this is the facet for the medial condyle, the femur.
So where it's going to articulate with.
Notice how smooth it is over here, but on the anterior, the posterior aspect of it, but the anterior aspect is quite bumpy
and with a lot of the ridges in this way.
Again, you have the muscles and the tendons that are attached to it to hold it in place.
And here you have your femur, this is the anterior view, this is the posterior view.
So this is the head of the femur.
And right over here, this is the fovea capidus that you see here.
This is the neck of the femur over here.
Now this is your greater trochanter, this is the lesser trochanter.
And between the greater and the lesser trochanter, we have this inter trochanteric line.
Now this is the gluteal tuberosity, and this is the linear aspera that you see over here.
As you said, the linear aspera, it bifurcates into the medial, the medial and the lateral supracondylar lines.
And as we go down, we have the intracondylar fossa over here that we see in the posterior aspect.
And then this is your lateral condyle, and this is the medial condyle.
And this is the adductor tubercle that you see right over here, the adductor tubercle.
There it is again over here.
You can see on the anterior aspect of the femur.
And also this is the patellar surface.
So this is the part that's going to be articulating it over here.
This part is going to be articulating over here.
And this part and this part is going to be in contact with the lateral epicondylar over here.
Hold on, this is the lateral, the candle is going to come over here this way.
And then the middle is going to be over here.
So again, they're going down now, bonds the appendicular skeleton.
All right, so moving downwards, we're going to be looking at the next two bonds, which are the tibia and the fibula.
And then we're going to be looking at your metatarsals and phalanges.
And that should be about it.
So moving forward, so your leg, your lower leg, it's made up of the two parallel bonds, the tibia,
and the fibula.
Now, the tibia, this is the much thicker and stronger of the two bonds, and it's located medially.
Now, the fibula, this is the bone that's located more lateral.
It's located lateral to the tibia.
The fibula, it's not a weight-bearing bone.
It doesn't articulate with the femur.
It articulates proximally and distally with the tibia.
Several muscles, they originate from the fibula, so again, it serves as attachment points.
Its job more is to help stabilize the tibia also.
So it kind of helps prevent you from kind of tipping over.
Now, the tibia, this is the medial of the two leg bones.
And this is the bone that received the weight from the femur and the transmittes to the foot.
So this is the stronger of the two bones, as I said.
Now, both of these bones, they're connected by this intra-RCS membrane.
Again, this is connective tissue.
Now, superiorly on the tibia, we find the medial and lateral condyles.
Now, they're separated by this irregular projection that's called the intracondular eminence.
Now, the tibial condyles, they are tickly with the corresponding condyles of the femur.
The inferior region of the lateral tibial condyles, they're bare facet that indicates the side
of the proximal tibial fibular joint.
Now, inferior to the condyles, the tibial anterior surface displays a rough tibial tuberosity
to where the patello ligament attaches to.
Now, the tibial shaft is a triangular and cross-section.
Now, neither tibial-sharp anterior border nor its medial surface is covered by muscle.
So they can be felt just deep to the skin along their entire length.
Dicily, the tibia is flat where it articulates with the teles of the foot.
A needle to the joint surface is an inferior projection that we call the medial malleolus.
This forms this medial bulge of our angle.
Now, the fibular notch on the lateral surface of the tibia, it participates in the distal tibial-fibular joint.
Now, we already talked about the fibula.
Now, this stick-like-looking bone, it articulates proximally and distally with the tibia.
Now, proximally, it articulates at its head, and the distal end, we have the lateral malleolus.
Now, the lateral malleolus, this is what forms the bulgeus on the lateral aspect of your foot.
And this is what articulates with the teles.
Now, let's look at this picture over here.
So here you have your tibia and fibula.
So notice, again, the fibula is found on the lateral aspect, and immediately you have the tibia.
So here's your tibia, here's your fibula.
And between the two, you have the intra-aseous membrane.
Now, let's look up over here.
This is your medial condyle.
You have your lateral condyle over here.
This is the tibial tuberosity.
And this is the intercondular eminence right over here.
Now, as you go down, you could see the anterior border of the tibia.
This is the medial malleolus, and over here, we have the inferior articular-- we cannot see it,
but again, the inferior articular surface over here.
Now, on the fibula, this is the lateral malleolus over here.
And this is the inferior tibia fibula joint right over here, this area, where the two bones meet.
And as you go to the top, you also have a superior tibial fibula joint.
So again, it's the head of the fibula that's articulating with the tibia over here.
Now, let's see.
As we move forward, we can see another picture destroying you.
This is a photograph now that shows you the tibial tuberosity and the lateral condyle.
And over here, here, this is another picture of the lateral condyle.
And this is where it's telling you that the fibula articulates with here.
You can see it at this point right here, this deprension.
And this is another line.
So remember, I said a lot of muscles attached over to the tibia.
So right over here at this line, this is one of the muscles called the soleus attaches to you over here.
Now, again, going to clinical or homocytic imbalances, a POTS fracture.
It occurs at the distal end of the fibula, the tibia or sometimes both.
And this is very common to see in sports injury.
So here you go.
Again, so when you're looking at this looks like the fibula that's been fractured over here.
So again, this is an example of, yeah, it is a fibula that says right here, part of the fibula's fracture.
So this is an example of a POTS fracture.
So again, this is distal, the distal end of this bone.
Then you see over here, you have your ankles bones, which you're going to be talking about next.
Now, your foot is made up of bones that include the tarsus, the metatarsus and the phalanges.
Now, the tarsus, they're made up of seven tarsal bones that form the posterior half of your foot.
Now, your body weight is cured primarily by the talus and the calcaneus.
Now, the calcaneus, this is your heel bone.
Now, as for the talus, the talus, first of all, it sits on top of the calcaneus,
but the talus superiorly, it articulates with both your tibia and your fibula.
Now, going back to the calcaneus, I'm sure you guys heard of your Achilles or the Achilles tendon.
Now, this tendon, it attaches to the calcaneus.
Part of the calcaneus that's touching the ground, that's called the calcaneal tuberosity.
The part that's curing the talus, that's called the sussentacular tali or the teller shelf.
Other bones that make up your tarsals, they include the cuboid, the navicular,
and then you have the medial, intermediate, and lateral cuneiform bones.
Now, the tibia, it articulates with the talus at the trochle of the talus.
And the cuboid and cuneiform bones, they articulate with the metatarsal bones anteriorly.
So, as we move forward, there's five metatarsal bones.
They're number one through five, and the first one being the helix.
So, the helix is your big toe, and then the five is the little toe.
Now, the enlarged head of metatarsal one, your helix, it forms the ball of your foot.
Then we have the phalanges, these are the toes of your foot.
There's 14 bones that form it.
And just like as it's on the hand, the very first digit one, it has especially into itself.
Remember, on your thumb, on your hand, it's called the polex.
Now, on the foot, it's called the helix.
So, again, this is your great toe.
Now, this also has only two bones.
Okay, again, just like in the hand, there's only two bones.
You have the same thing going on over here in your foot.
Now, digits two through five, they have the three bones that are present.
You have your distal, middle, and proximal phalanx that we see.
So, let's look at this illustration of the foot over here.
So, this is a calcaneus bone, and you can see the talus that's on top of that.
This is the trochle of the talus.
This is the part that's going to be our tipping with the tibia.
Then you have the navicular bone and the cuboid bone.
The remaining three are the medial, intermediate, and lateral cuneiform bones.
Then you have the metatarsals.
One, two, three, four, and five.
These are the five metatarsals.
After that, then we have the phalanges.
Again, notice there's only two bones that make up the phalanges in the helix.
Okay, this is your great toe.
And then the remaining, they have one, two, three parts.
They have a proximal, a middle, and a distal phalanx.
It's another side view that you can see on this bone.
Now, this is a calcaneal tuberosity.
So, this is the part that you're actually stepping on.
This is the part that's making contact with the ground.
So, what else can we see over here?
So, this is a teller shelf.
You can see over here that the talus is sitting on top of partially.
You can see the medial malleolar facet over here also.
This is where the medial malleosis is going to come into contact with.
Then, over here, you have the navicular bone here.
And then you can see the medial cuneiform and the intermediate cuneiform over here.
You can see the first metatarsal over here and then the two phalanx that are attached to it.
And again, this is a lateral view.
In this view, you can see the lateral malleolar facet over here that's on the talus.
Again, you can see the calcaneus very clearly.
There's a cuboid bone now, which you're not able to see in the previous picture.
And also, you can see the lateral cuneiform as well as the intermediate cuneiform over here.
And over here, you can see very clearly your fifth metatarsal bone.
You can see 1, 2, 3, the phalanges.
Now, as far as the arches of the foot go, they're maintained by interlocking foot bones, ligaments, and tendons.
And they allow the foot to bear weight.
Now, we have three arches, the lateral longitudinal, the medial longitudinal, and the transverse arch.
The lateral longitudinal arch, it's very low.
It elevates the lateral part of the foot just enough to redistribute some of the weight to the calcaneus and the head of the fifth metatarsal.
Now, the cuboid, this is a keystone bone of this arch.
The medial margin from the heel to the head of the first metatarsal, it curves, it arches upwards, okay, above the ground.
And this is where forms this medial longitudinal arch.
Now, the transverse arch, it runs obliquely from one side of the foot to the other.
It follows the line of the joints between the tarsal and the metatarsal.
Together, the arches of the foot, they form a half dome that distributes about half of a person standing and walking weight to the heel bone,
and then the other half to the heads of the metatarsals.
So, when you look at this feature over here, here you have your medial longitudinal arch, and this is going to end up lifting up the medial aspect of your foot upwards.
And then the lateral longitudinal arch, now this is going to curve it up not as high, but again, low, this is going to be a lower curve that it's going to be lifting it up.
And then going all the way across, you have the transverse arch.
So, again, this is just another picture of next ray.
It's kind of showing, well, it's hard to see anything over here.
But you can't really see what's going on as far as the arches or anything.
But what you're looking at here, this is the medial aspect of your right foot.
So clearly you can see the talus, the calcaneus.
You can see the tarsals over here, and then you can see the metatarsals, and you can see the flanges also.
Now, fallen arches are also called a flat feet, and they result from stress on tendons and ligaments of the feet.
Now, this can be caused by standing immobile for long periods of time, or for running on hard surfaces without a proper arch in support.
So again, if you have bad shoes, it could happen.
Or again, if you're just standing up for very long times, you're not moving about.
And again, if you don't have good proper support, this can end up occurring.
Now, let's look at some of the development aspects of the skeleton.
Now, the infant skull, it has more bones than adult skull does.
And I think we talked about this earlier on at the beginning of the chapter.
Now, the skull bones, such as the mandible and the frontor bones, are unfuse.
As a child grows, these bones, they start coming together and start to fuse.
Now, the skull bones, they're connected by what's called these fontanels.
And these are unassified remnants of the fibrous membranes.
And this also helps ease birth, and it allows for brain growth to occur.
So this is the soft part of the baby scalp that we're talking about.
Now, the four fontanels that are present on a baby, these are the anterior, posterior, the mastoid, and the stenoidal fontanels.
So you can look over here.
So these are the frontal bone, and this is the anterior fontanel.
And this is the posterior fontanel that we see over here.
This is the mastoid fontanel that we see over here, and then this is the sphenoidal fontanel that's present.
And again, this is going to allow for this entire skull to grow, and is also, in addition to that, for the brain to grow.
Now, there are some congenital abnormalities that may distort the skull.
So one of the things that we see are the cleft palate.
This is the most common condition.
So there's no medial fusion of the right and left palate, half of the palate.
This, it interferes with sucking for the baby when it's born, and it could lead to aspiration of foods into the lung,
which may result in aspiration pneumonia.
So here you go, you see a baby that's born with a cleft palate and lip.
Now, this is very easily treated, you know, a surgeon, an ENT, you know, somebody that has some knowledge, they can fix this quite easily in a baby.
And oftentimes you've probably seen, here, you can see this foot over here.
Again, this has been surgically repaired, and, you know, it's looking much better than now.
And also, most importantly, this child is not going to end up aspirating, which could lead to death.
Now, at birth, the cranium is much larger than what the face is.
At nine months, the cranium is about half the adult size, which is quite significant.
The mandible and maxilla, these are still shortened, but as you age, they will start to lengthen.
Now, the arms and legs, they grow out of faster rate than the head and the trunk, and this leads to what we call these adult proportions.
So differential growth transforms are rounded for short and skull of newborn to the sloping skull of adult.
As you come over here, during the growth of a human, the arms and legs, they grow faster than the head and the trunk.
So when you look at it in this picture, you can see it, you know, depending at all these different age groups, as this is occurring.
The primary curvatures of the thorax and sacrum, they're convex at birth, and this was resolved in this C-shaped spine.
Second, when you look at a baby when it's born, you know, it's cradled up, you know, it's curled up like a C, and it happens.
The reason that it occurs is because of the shape that the spine is in, but the secondary curvatures of the cervical and lumbar regions, convex anteriorly as a child will develop.
So here you see, notice how this child is C-shaped.
You notice the spine, how it is.
You know, when you're curled up inside your mother's womb for nine months, this is how you're growing, this is going to happen.
Now, as we age, the intervertebral discs, they become thin, they're less hydrated and they're less elastic.
The risk of disternations, it increases significantly.
Now, several centimetres of height is lost by the time you're around age 55.
So, you know, when you're born, you're small, and then as you're, by the time you end up reaching, you know, your 20s, you know, you continually grow.
And then usually between, again, the ages of your mid-20s, again, anywhere from 18 to 25, you stop, you know, that's when you reach, your body will no longer grow.
So from that point on, actually, yeah, after the age of 25, all the way up to 50, 55, there's going to be no growth going on, meaning, you know, whatever your height is, it's going to say the same.
But right around this age, okay, around 55 years old, then you're going to start to shrink again, all right?
And the reason you did this happening partially is because of this.
The causal cartridges, they're all also start to ossify.
So now you have a thorax that's a little bit rigid, and you cannot breathe as well as you used to before, so, you know, you're breathing more shallowly.
So you have a less efficiency of gas exchange from taking place. There's also bone mass that's been lost.
So, you know, your risk of fractures are also increased significantly.
Now, the appendicular skeletons taken several from congenital abnormalities as well.
One of the things that could happen is hip dysplasia.
Now, this occurs slightly over 1% of infants. Now, the acetabulum, it forms incompletely, or the ligaments, they're too loose.
And this allows the head of the femur to slip out of the socket.
Now, treatments for this, they include splints or a harness to hold a femur in place.
Sometimes you have surgery to tighten them ligament as well.
So, this is it for this chapter. This concludes the final part for chapter 7.
If you like it, please give a thumbs up. If you have any questions, please feel free to email me back.
Also, please be sure to share with your friends or anybody else that you may feel that could find this useful.
And also, please be sure to subscribe. When you subscribe, you guys will get immediate notifications.
You'll be the first ones to find out when new videos are posted.
If you need any additional supplements, you have any more questions, email me directly, or leave it in the comments below.
below. Thank you again and best of luck with your exams.